This episode is sponsored by Blinkist.
Blinkist takes all of the need-to-know
information from thousands of nonfiction books
and condenses it down to just 15 minutes and you
can go to blinkist.com/microcosmos to learn more.
One of the most frequent questions we get asked
on Journey to the Microcosmos is how James,
our master of microscopes, stays safe
while gathering and studying samples.
After all, as beautiful as the microcosmos is,
there are plenty of parasites and pathogens in
there that we’d prefer to keep under
the microscope and out of our bodies.
But while James has simple and effective
guidelines to protect his health—like
making sure he always washes his hands before and
after handling samples, and never venturing into
a pond with an open wound—there are times
when those measures don’t quite cut it.
These are the times when no matter how much
you protect yourself outside or inside,
the microcosmos gets the best of you.
These are the times of the dust mite.
Now we don’t usually start these videos with
a warning, but we’re going to do that today.
While working on this video, at least 4
members of the Journey to the Microcosmos team
found themselves having a bit of a
crisis about how clean their homes were.
If you’ve found yourself sneezing and wheezing and
running around miserable with a runny
nose because of dust, this arachnid
is probably the culprit—though perhaps
not in the way you would expect.
Dust mites are small in the grand scheme of
things, but large in the microcosmos, hitting just
around 300 micrometers in length. Their bodies are
decked out with four pairs of legs ending in feet
that act like suction cups as they wander in their
quest for three things: water, food, and darkness.
Dust mites love humidity because their
lives depend on it. They don’t drink water
so much as they osmosis it into them, relying on
a salt-filled gland near their mouth to absorb
water vapor from the air around them. So if their
surroundings become more arid, an adult dust mite
will wither away until it eventually dies.
This is a challenge for dust mites that live
in places with seasons, where wet and rainy falls
give way to dry winters. To survive those shifts,
they rely on the resilience of their
younger brethren—the nymphs—whose
forms are able to withstand the lack of moisture.
The seasons of the dust mite’s life was one of the
important clues that helped scientists in the 20th
century understand their role in dust allergies.
Scientists identified dust as the source of some
kind of allergen in the 1920s, but they were not
sure what it was exactly about dust that did it.
They just knew that people all over the globe
suffered from dust allergies, and that these
allergies were often seasonal, peaking in the
autumn, particularly after warm, humid summers2.
And other possible sources, like animal dander
or mold, just didn’t quite fit right with the
seasonality of the allergy. But in the 1960s,
scientists in the Netherlands and Japan realized
that the dust mite might be the culprit.
They’re found in large numbers in the dust that
lines the unwashed and untouched corners of our
homes, their populations peaking in time with the
runny noses and bleary eyes of dust allergies.
But while experiments confirmed that mites
really were the source of people’s sensitivities
to house dust, it wasn’t clear what made them
so special. So, we’ll get to that in a bit...
James often finds dust mites in the humidity
chambers he uses to keep his microbes alive.
These chambers are made up of a
dish lined with wet toilet paper,
which is just about all a dust mite needs to feel
right at home—especially when there’s potentially
some delicious microbes to munch on. So to keep
those other microbes from becoming a mite meal,
James has to regularly clean out
and disinfect the humidity chamber.
Now, that cleaning might get rid of the
dust mites in the humidity chamber, but
the problem is that our houses are full of
food for them because our houses are full of
us—of flakes from our skin that shed and gather
all around and sustain the invisible mite.
And this is a problem not just because it
means the mite can thrive in our homes.
It’s a problem because food means poop. Over
the course of its life, a mite will produce
about 1000 pieces of poop that are roughly the
size of a grain of pollen. Inside those bits of
fecal matter are enzymes that help the dust mite
eat its own poop and get nutrients that it might
not have gotten the first time around.
But should the dust mite choose to not
revisit its prior meals, the feces will float
around the room, attached to other particles
until eventually they settle down—perhaps on
a pillow, or on a pet’s bed, or a car seat.
It’s like we’re living in a gigantic snow globe,
except that the snow... is dust mite feces.
In 1981, researchers confirmed the bad news about
this animal’s poop— people are allergic to it.
To be more specific, they confirmed
that dust mite poop contains specific
proteins that many people are allergic to.
So if you’re airing out some sheets and you start
sneezing, what you might actually be reacting
to is dust mite feces flying around the air.
Now, we apologize for this mental image but it
is reality, and it has embedded in our heads,
so we have to share it with you as well. But
we can offer what might be a small comfort:
there is another allergen from dust
mites that has nothing to do with poop.
Dust mites have a fairly lengthy mating process,
sometimes taking up to two days to finish—this
is a pretty lengthy time for any organism, but
especially for an animal that’s only got about
100 total days to live. Over the course of their
life, the female dust mite will lay up to 80 eggs,
which hatch into larvae that then go through
several different stages of development
before becoming adults
With each passing stage,
the dust mite sheds its exoskeleton, leaving
behind its youth. And that exoskeleton provides
some of the other allergens for people react to.
But though that is something people are sometimes
allergic to, it really is mostly just the poop
that sets off people’s allergies. So I guess there
really wasn’t that much comfort there after all.
And even for a trained and cautious
microbiologist, dust mites can
become an unwelcome surprise.
Once, James brought home some samples taken from
a water dish that his neighbor left outside for
their cat. The surface was covered in tiny round
things, and James thought they might be rotifers.
But when he looked at the surface of the scum
under the microscope, there were no charming
rotifers to be found. It was mites, just
hundreds of them crawling around the slide.
It was so unpleasant that James
immediately bleached the slide.
Now, he’s not sure if that sample is the reason,
but for days after, James kept sneezing and
having to deal with a runny nose, all of
which pointed to a potential mite invasion.
Fortunately though, our homes are not a utopia
for dust mites. What they really need is dark,
which is why they prefer to dig themselves deep
into carpets and other soft things that give them
space to burrow4. Dust mites have a harder time
with materials like suede that are difficult to
hide themselves in5, and they usually avoid
hard surfaces that are exposed to light.
So for James, his weapons against
the mite invasion were clear:
a vacuum, a mattress cleaner, and a strong
UV light bulb. It is one of the more ignoble
ends to one of our organisms. We don’t like
to hurt them, unless they are hurting us.
But I am sure there’s a dust mite somewhere in our
homes right now, settling into a soft, dark abode
of its own, with hardly a care in the world for
the battle that was waged to bring you this video.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And we would like to thank Blinkist
for sponsoring today’s episode.
Blinkist is an app that takes the best insights
and need-to-know information from over 4,000
nonfiction books and condenses them down into
just 15 minutes that you can read or listen to.
Maybe you have an idea for a podcast that you
just haven’t been able to get off the ground yet?
Then we highly recommend checking
out Everybody Has a Podcast
(Except You) by Justin, Travis,
and Griffin McElroy on Blinkist.
It’s a funny and inspiring, hands-on guide
to making your own podcast and it will
walk you through everything from choosing
a topic to building an audience and you
can check that out right now on Blinkist.
It can be hard to find the time to sit down and
learn, but with Blinkist you can explore their
massive library of books in categories like
self-help, business, science, and history.
And if you’re one of the first 100 people to
sign up today using Blinkist.com/microcosmos,
you can get free unlimited access for 7 days
and you’ll also get 25% off if you decide to
get a full membership. Check out the link in
the description to start your free 7-day trial.
It might be that your name is coming up on
the screen right now. And if that is the case,
I just want to say “Thank you!” These
are all the names of our Patreon patrons.
They are the people who make this project possible
and without them, we would not be able to continue
exploring all of the nooks and crannies and ins
and outs of the tiny world that surrounds us.
So, thank you all, to all of our patrons,
and if you would like to become one of them,
you can go to Patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James Weiss, you can check
out Jam and Germs on Instagram or TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere  nearby.
There's a tickle in my nose.
Oh god!